and now nine urban dictionary
definitions you need to know
fart Blanche permission to fart freely
Carrie was given fart Blanche around the
house for the weekend bro pocalypse a
large gathering of bros on a mission to
get drunk quarter beers are a sure sign
of the coming bro pocalypse make it snow
to throw diamonds or cocaine in the air
I'm so rich when I hit the club I make
it snow
dank RuPt to be out of marijuana
Johnny couldn't pack a bowl because he
was dang corrupt moobs excessive breast
fat on a male I love to bury my face
between his moobs clam jam the female
version of a [ __ ] block jenny is a dick
because she clammed jammed Rachel know
she lies to ignore friends in public for
your smartphone Jenny is a dick for no
lysing at brunch meat sweats to perspire
while eating large amounts of meat our
dinner date was ruined when Mark got the
meat sweats screw veneer items kept
after sleeping with someone
Jenny's new shirt is a screw veneer from
Ted's house Yolo carpe diem for stupid
people let's have another drink
because Yolo for more definitions visit
urbandictionary.com be sure to look up
beef walk it's quite amusing